comment travailler en libéral ou
s'installer dans un territoire quand on
débute dans le métier
ce sont les réponses que sont venus
chercher médecins sages femmes
infirmiers ou encore interne
il ya un réel besoin dans les yvelines
comme en france de façon générale qui
est des médecins qui s'installent
il y avait il ya 30 ans 80 % des
étudiants diplômés s'installer en
médecine libérale et aujourd'hui ils
sont 13% à s'installer en libéral sur
saint quentin en yvelines les personnels
de santé dit de recours tels que les
médecins généralistes les
kinésithérapeutes ou encore les
dentistes sont quatre pour 5000
habitants un chiffre dans la moyenne
nationale à l'échelle de l'agglomération
l'institut de promotion de la santé peut
accompagner les professionnels
intéressés ce qu'on a pu faire pour
l'instant c'est c'est repérer ces
indicateurs
c'est un appui administratif au montage
des dossiers notamment par exemple les
diagnostics territoriaux des études de
faisabilité donc aider à mettre en place
et puis faciliter les liens avec
d'autres professionnels les centres
hospitaliers etc
sur un territoire sur l'agglomération il
n'y a pas deux comme une
saint-quentinoise considéré en déficit
mais celle de trappes est tout de même
classée par la rs l' agence régionale de
santé
comment fragilité sur l'offre dite de
premier recours